- Here's the paradox we're facing in 2025.
We are building AI agents
that can reason, act,
and plan autonomously.
Agents that should be able to achieve
your business outcomes,
optimize business operations,
and also make real time decisions.
Yet most organizations
are sitting on petabytes,
sometimes exabytes of data,
that their agent simply
can't use effectively.
Your customer service logs
in S3, product documentation,
some sort of a distributed file system,
years of transaction history in S3,
data that has been perfectly stored,
governed, and backed up.
But there's a gap, a critical gap,
in terms of where the data sits
and how your agent needs to access it.
Here's the irony.
The data is already there.
You've invested in terms of storing it,
backing it up, and protecting it.
But when the agent needs to recall
a customer interaction from years ago,
or find a pattern across
millions of transaction history,
or tap into institution knowledge
when it needs to make a
decision, it hits a wall
because agents don't just need data.
They need memory, they need context,
they need to be able
to learn, collaborate,
and adapt in real time.
The breakthrough everyone's chasing
isn't about building smarter models.
We are already getting
pretty good at that.
The real breakthrough lies
when your existing data
becomes agent-ready.
So turning passive storage
into active memory,
transforming archived information
into accessible intelligence
that your agents can actually work with,
and that's exactly what we're here today
because the most powerful agent
is only as good as the data
architecture behind it.
So let's talk about
putting your data to work,
but not just for analytical or compliance,
but for AI agents that are shaping up
the next generation of
applications in enterprises.
I'm Venkata Sistla.
I'm a senior worldwide
specialist solutions architect
here at AWS.
So from today's agenda perspective,
we'll cover these topics.
So first of all, we'll start off
with covering a few fundamentals
in terms of what makes
an agent truly agentic
versus just another simple chat bot.
Then we'll dive deep into what it takes
to build context-aware agents.
We'll also explore
building scalable agents
using managed versus
self-managed approach.
Then we'll dive deeper
into how AWS storage
becomes the external
brain for your AI agents.
Finally, we'll leave you
with a few architectural
examples and references
and a few resources that you
can take away after the session
so you can learn and dive deeper.
These numbers should grab your attention
'cause we are looking at
a massive transformation
that's happening right now.
Gartner predicts by 2028
that one in three enterprise applications
will have agentic AI.
That's nearly up from
less than 1% from 2024,
and we are also talking about
$120 million transformation
that's happening right now.
Sorry, $120 billion market by 2030,
which tells you that
this isn't just a hype
and enterprises are making
serious investments,
and I'm also seeing this
firsthand from my customers
where they're transitioning from building
simple Q and H ad bots to
really complex multi-agents
as part of their enterprises
to solve complex problems.
The question isn't
whether this will happen,
rather would you be ready when it happens?
And some of the customers
that I've worked with
include Ericsson, Thomson
Reuters, Experian, so on,
who are actually going really deep in
in terms of deploying
agentic architectures
as part of their enterprise applications.
Agentic AI promises to enhance
productivity and efficiency.
You know, taking on problems
that were difficult to be
solved by traditional software,
simplifying integration, and
also finding answers and data
that were previously invisible.
Agentic AI systems autonomously decide
how to accomplish a task,
taking on prompts in the
form of a natural language,
and adapting their plan
as they're learning more new information.
But there is still a human in the mix.
So human essentially gives
the overall sets the goal
in the form of natural language
and exercises supervisory control.
So what makes it truly special
is their ability to sort of
learn and improve over time.
So every interaction, every new
I guess piece of information
that you give it to the agent,
it essentially stores it in memory
and then adapts for its
future conversation.
This diagram illustrates
what transforms a simple LLM
into an autonomous agent,
which is capable of
solving complex problems.
The key difference here is autonomy
because these systems don't
just respond to prompts,
but they're actively working
towards accomplishing towards
a specific objective or goal
set by the human.
So going with the components,
the first we have is LLM.
LLM's more capable or responsible
for reasoning capabilities.
So it'll give you the
understanding of the intent,
as well as making
decisions about next steps.
Second, you have tools.
Tools give ability the agent
to interact with internal
and external environment,
whether that's extracting data,
executing certain functions,
or also interacting with systems.
Third, memory.
Memory ensures continuity.
Agent doesn't need to start
from scratch all the time.
It essentially builds or
resumes from where it left off.
Third is context awareness.
Essentially allows the agent
to understand its environment
so that it can adapt its behavior
based on who it's interacting with.
Finally, prompt engineering.
Prompt engineering defines
agent's role, capabilities,
and constraints that it
needs to operate with.
What makes this powerful
is the shift in how we interact with AI
'cause instead of
step-by-step instructions
that we are used to or over
the last couple of years ago,
you're now providing the oral goal
in the form of natural language,
and the agent then autonomously
plans the required steps
to achieve that goal, and
continues to deliver so.
This is the million dollar question
that every organization's
grappling with right now.
Most context-aware agents
don't just need a good LLM.
That's just table stakes.
You need persistent memory,
real time data access,
and the ability to learn
and adapt over time.
Most importantly, you need all of this
with enterprise scale,
enterprise grade scale,
security and governance.
Let's dive into what this
actually looks like in practice.
Agent memory is a computational
exo cortex for AI agents,
which means it's a system
that combines LLM's built-in
memory with persistent storage
so that it's able to remember,
retrieve, and adapt over time
with past experiences
and the new information
that it's trying to learn.
Just like human memory,
it helps agents to build
knowledge over time,
maintain context across conversations,
also learn behavior adaptations
based on interactions.
Transforming from one-off responders
to reliable and truly intelligent systems.
Our customer conversations
show that one-off interactions
are really good at capturing
the initial or the first of impression,
but the real value comes from the agents
having ability to remember the
context, learn from history,
and also adapt the overall experience.
So memory management isn't just a feature.
It's the core infrastructure
that turns reactive agents
into truly intelligent systems
that deliver sustained
value for your enterprises.
Let me show you a real world example
that perfectly illustrate
why memory matters.
So the difference in user
experience is really dramatic,
and that actually translates
directly to the business value.
Pay attention to how the
customer conversation...
Sorry, how this particular
conversation flow
changes completely when the
agent's able to remember
the past conversation and build upon.
Without agent memory,
there are several critical limitations
that we will end up hitting.
First, inability to maintain
conversation continuity.
It cannot really build upon or
reference previous dialogue.
No behavioral adaptation.
So essentially, it cannot
learn user feedback
or adjust approaches
based on your preferences.
Third, lack of personal objectives.
So without personal objectives,
then it cannot really
sustain the overall session
or achieve the goal set by you.
And lastly, missing personalization.
So it cannot really develop
user specific preferences,
and I've got some examples
in the future slides
that will demonstrate
why your personalization
is very important trait for AI agents.
There's a research that was
done by Microsoft and Salesforce
and the study's called, LLMs get lost
in multi-turn conversations.
So the study found that most of the LLMs
experience significant performance drop
in extended conversations
primarily because those LLMs
make premature assumptions very early on,
and they essentially fail to recover
when they're proved wrong
on those assumptions.
That exactly goes back
to the conversation continuity limitation
that we just discussed above.
Here's another frustrating example
of, you know, agents without memory.
Every conversation starts from scratch.
Notice how the agent asked
for the iPhone model twice
within just two days apart.
This creates a terrible user experience
and feels the agent really
robotic and unhelpful.
I love this quote which says, you know,
"AI agent without memory
is like a goldfish.
Everything's new every three seconds."
When we implement proper memory,
we unlock three key capabilities
that transform the user experience.
First, contextual intelligence,
meaning the agent not just
understands what you're asking,
but why you're asking it.
Second, user preferences.
It truly personalizes interactions.
The agent's able to remember or adapt
based on how you work and communicate.
Third is knowledge retention.
So with the continued interactions,
agent builds its own knowledge
base about the world,
the facts, the things, the participants,
and it gets essentially
smarter with every interaction.
So these are nice to have features.
They're really essential for
enterprise level adoption.
So now let's dive a little
deeper into agentic memory.
Understanding these core concepts
will help you design AI
systems to work at scale,
and think of it also
you're building neural
pathways for your AI
'cause if you get this right,
everything else from an
AI agentic deployment
becomes much easier.
Agentic memory is really critical,
especially when you're building
personalized AI systems
'cause it enables adaptive learning
through, you know, each interaction,
allows agents to understand
individual preferences,
communication styles, and
also behavioral patterns.
Without access to persistent memory,
even the most sophisticated agents
or chat bots cannot really provide
the personalized user experience
that we are demanding
from this day and age
of AI applications.
This is probably a personal reflection
of me looking at the last couple of years.
You know, GPT models have provided
broad general knowledge to begin with.
So we quickly introduced RAG
to ground those GPT models
to our proprietary data.
But what we quickly realized was
as RAG architecture scaled,
we encountered that there is a limitation
with finite context windows,
which limited us with the
conversation continuity problem
that we, you know, tried
to uncover previously,
as well as personalization
in the oral experience
of how we interact with AI.
So agent memory essentially
extends the rack capabilities
by providing persistent
memory across sessions,
enabling agents to build context
over multiple interactions,
and delivering really relevant
and personalized experience to users.
So the RAG concept doesn't go away,
it is essentially getting extended
into the concept of agent memory
where it's trying to give
us multiple benefits.
Data retrieval becomes a fundamental
to agent's memory architecture.
Effective systems must
intelligently surface
the relevant context from
vast stores of user stories
and past interaction data.
So this requires sophisticated algorithms
to precisely identify which
elements of past conversation
would really supplement
the current context
of existing interaction,
enabling truly adaptive learning
that compounds over time.
And advanced systems still
require higher order form
of information retrieval
organization and retention
that mirrors human cognitive process,
which we now define as agent's memory.
So there are two
fundamental types of memory
that every agent needs.
Short term memory it's
like a RAM in a computer
which is mostly temporary
and session based.
Long term memory is like a hard drive,
which is more persistent
and supplements evolutionary learning.
So this dual memory architecture
enables both immediate responsiveness
and also sustained improvement over time.
Long term memory is also crucial
for enabling AI self-evolution
where agents automatically learn, adapt,
and refine their reasoning
based on accumulated examples
and interactions of data.
So by incorporating long-term memory,
AI agents becomes like adaptive teammates
where they're really getting specialized
in their skill and the knowledge over time
as a subject matter experts
just like humans as we would evolve into.
So let's dive a little deeper
into the short term memory concept.
So short term memory
is all about maintaining
the conversation flow
and immediate context.
So in this particular example,
see how the agent's able to
remember the iPhone model
from the earlier conversation
and provide really
specific help to the user.
So this requires storing
and retrieving conversation
history in real time.
The agent needs to quickly
access recent messages
and understand the current context,
and maintain that state
across multiple interactions.
From a storage perspective,
this means that we require really fast
and low latency access to the data.
Think of this as agents working memory.
It needs immediately accessible
but also doesn't necessarily
need to persist forever.
Short-term memory units last anywhere
from seconds to days depending
upon the application needs.
So there are two terminologies
when we mention short-term memory.
There is working memory and
there is short-term memory.
Often the terms short-term
memory and working memory,
sorry, working memory
are interchangeably used,
but there is a clear distinction.
Working memory is a special
type of short-term memory
that is used specifically
for actively processing
information for that specific task.
Short term memory is a
broader temporary storage
for the oral session.
So not all working memory
is short-term memory,
but all short term
memory is working memory.
So working memory is the doing part.
On the other hand, short term memory
is the holding part for that session.
Episodic memory is the agent's record
of specific events and interactions,
just like human's personal memory
of our own life experiences.
It stores conversation history,
summaries of important events,
and individual occurrences
with specifically attached metadata
such as timestamps and participants.
Conversation memory is a
specific type of episodic memory
that is essentially
focused on chat history
or user preferences that you see here.
It keeps a complete
record of conversations,
who said what and when,
and also helping agents
staying consistent
throughout interactions,
and it is also able to refer back
to the earlier parts of the conversation
and really, you know, provide
the contextualized responses
as part of the interaction.
So the system continuously
updates its memory blocks
as the conversation progresses.
So in short, episodic memory
is the what happened storage
and the conversational memory
is the what we talked about storage.
So long term memories
are where things get really interesting,
and this is about learning
and personalization over time.
Notice how the agent's able to remember
the specific preferences
from few days ago?
It is able to remember the
brand, the employee discount,
and also the color of the headphones.
So this isn't just storing data.
It's about extracting and
organizing those insights
that can be applied to
the future interactions.
So essentially, agent builds up
a profile of user preferences
that gets richer and
more accurate over time
with every interaction.
So from a technical standpoint,
this requires a very sophisticated
storage and retrieval
system that can quickly find
relevant preferences based
upon the given context.
So this is where the vector
databases and semantic search
becomes really crucial for
the oral agentic performance.
Next we have semantic memory.
So semantic memory is an agent's
organized knowledge base.
Everything the agent
knows about the world,
including the facts, the concepts,
how things relate to each other.
This includes knowledge bases.
Essentially, that's a collection
of factual information.
Entity memory, which is specific details
about people's, facts, and things.
Third is persona memory,
which is role-based knowledge
that essentially guides the agent
in terms of how it should
behave with every interaction.
So semantic memory is essentially
agent-structured world knowledge
that enables consistent reasoning.
So the most common real
world example is RAG.
So we've used RAG over
the last couple of years,
which is able to take
the factual documents
or the proprietary data that we supplied,
and able to provide
contextualized responses
only from the given factual information.
So in simple terms,
semantic memory is agent's encyclopedia
of facts and concepts that
it can further reference back
to be able to answer any
questions or future interactions,
also make decisions, and separate memories
from, you know, each other memories.
So it is able to, through this mechanism,
the agent's able to sort of
separate out the memories
for each every user profile.
Sorry.
In this particular example,
the agent has learned
the specific business
values or business rules.
So it's learned the return
policy, the employee discount,
and also the overall
product specification.
So this type of memory is
really particularly powerful
in the context of enterprises
because especially when
you have, you know,
company policies, factual documentation,
or various product catalogs,
when you have different
dimensions of information,
when you want agent to
find semantic meaning
or context across different dimensions,
semantic memory is where
it comes into play.
So rather than just storing
the raw conversation data,
the agent essentially
builds up a knowledge base
as you're seeing on the
right hand side as an example
with full of facts and relationships.
So this is where the integration
between your agent's memory
and your existing data
sources with your organization
becomes really crucial.
Third, summary memory.
Essentially shortly known as
distilling for key insights.
So summary memory is another
type of episodic memory
that distills keen insights
from longer interactions.
So practically, we can store
every single interaction in the storage,
but when we are looking to scale
the overall agentic performance,
retrieving every single
interaction from the storage
and then extracting the insights out of it
will be a very laborious task,
or it would be very performance intensive.
So which is why the
agent essentially stores
a summary of the very long conversation
with really key messages,
or the storyline of what
was the interaction about.
So in this particular example,
you can see it's talking about
the user bought the headphones,
there's a price match,
or, you know, found a cheaper price
and it was able to, you know,
do the price match as a result of it.
So it is also where you start
to see the value of agents,
you know, having the ability
to sort of learn and adapt,
you know, with the
summarization over time.
- Okay, thanks.
I'm John Mallory.
I'm a go to market specialist here at AWS,
and so I wanna switch gears now
and, you know, Venkata
just walked us through
the importance of both short
term and persistent memory
for building agents.
What I'd like to do is double click
into some common approaches
of how you do this,
and then layer in how
storage supports all of that.
So let's get started with
how you're going to build,
and deploy, and host agents.
You know, a very common design pattern
is a lot of AI builders wanna start off
using open source frameworks.
You know, like Strands Agent,
LangChain Llama agent, AutoGen.
There's a whole host of them out there
and they're really good because, you know,
they can accelerate experimentation,
and building, and learning.
They're, you know, have a lot
of packaged tools built in,
and, you know, they really can simplify
particularly using
interfaces and protocols
like MCP and agent to agent,
stitching all the components together.
But the challenge lies
in how do you start to
move this into production
because then you have to start to worry
about scaling infrastructure,
managing security,
managing the various types of memory
that Venkata talked about, and, you know,
gluing all these pieces
together, you know,
as you wanna scale to
hundreds or thousands of users
have very complex orchestrated
agentic workflows.
Make sure you've got the right guardrails
and safety and security around it.
It can quickly get very complicated.
You know, so this is
evidenced by a Gartner study
that over 40% of Agentic AI projects
will be canceled in 2027,
you know, due to unclear
business value, increasing cost,
and, you know, questionable
security and governance policies
that aren't going to meet
enterprise requirements.
So, but that being said,
we do see a lot of sophisticated customers
using self-managed frameworks.
There are a couple of other approaches.
You know, down on the left,
if you're just starting out your journey,
you wanna leverage the power of agents.
We have Amazon Queue in our quick suite,
which has agents packaged in
for common enterprise workloads.
You know, so you can really
leverage the power of agentic AI
without needing to build anything.
Next stop is the fully managed approach
using Amazon Bedrock
agents, which, you know,
really starts to stitch
all these pieces together,
handle key parts of the infrastructure
like hosting the LLMs, building
knowledge bases in RAG,
and orchestrating
multi-step agent workflow.
So that gives you a lot of
flexibility and, you know,
can help you get started quickly.
But the key thing is you
don't really have to choose
between a do-it-yourself approach
using these open source frameworks,
and some of the features
and capabilities of Bedrock.
You know, what we released back in July
and went GA in October
was a Bedrock AgentCore,
which removes a lot of the
undifferentiated heavy lifting
of building agents
where you can kinda take
a mix and match approach.
You can use your open source frameworks
and, you know, choose the
framework of your choice,
have your choice of models
both inside and outside of Bedrock,
but then to have these
AgentCore components
that really start to make
it a managed experience.
You know, so if you take like
runtime that handles compute
where you don't have to
worry about provisioning,
scaling, compute up
and down, it does that.
AgentCore memory reduces a lot
of the work you have to do to build
both the short term and
the long term memory
that Venkata talked about.
It automates a lot of that.
And then, you know, identity helps
with all the security and permissions,
and gateway can help orchestrate
between all the tools you're gonna use.
You know, so really this is
a great way to get started,
but even if you take this approach
and you use AgentCore memory,
you still need to think about storage
when it comes to building agents.
So before we dive into
the various components,
let's talk about a few of the challenges
you need to be mindful of
as you start this journey,
or, you know, even as you
evolve in this journey.
The first is you've gotta
make all of your data
accessible, discoverable, and actionable.
You know, agents that
create business value
are going to need to access
all forms of your data that you have
in your organization, or your
company, or your enterprise,
and this is everything
from structured data
that may live in data
warehouses, databases,
you know, transactional
data that, you know,
drives all of your business
transactions and billing,
and, you know, key use cases
that are gonna power the business daily
all the way to depending
on what industry you're in,
unstructured data of all forms.
You know, things like images,
video, call record logs,
if you're in specific
industries like healthcare,
medical records,
pathology reports, images.
Agents really need to
be able to understand
and choose from all of these data sets.
The second key challenge
is really privacy, and
security, and governance
because ultimately, you want the agents
to access as much data as they need
to be effective and to add value,
but you need to put guardrails on that
because God forbid you build an agent
that exposes sensitive,
let's say, patient data
to, you know, the world.
That can't happen.
So you've gotta have proper
governance and guardrails.
And then as Venkata discussed,
agents are gonna act if they're built
and really adding value autonomously
without human intervention
and achieve complex goals.
So you really need to monitor
this both to make sure
you don't have any data leakage
or, you know, governance breaches,
but also to collect data
on how to improve accuracy
and iterate as your
agents learn and evolve.
So you need to think about governance.
And finally, semantic search and storage
is key both for grounding
agents with data via RAG,
as well as the long-term memory.
And this isn't just theoretical.
I had a customer meeting this morning
with a large enterprise software customer
who they built some agents,
they've seen some business value,
and so they really wanna scale it,
but now they're thinking about
how do we build the data
foundation to do this.
Essentially they want an agentic layer
that they can bring the agents to the data
because if you start to
bring data to the agents,
now you're back with data sprawl
and trying to maintain data
fidelity across multiple copies.
So it really kind of brought
all these challenges to life
and they've got multiple data warehouses,
Snowflake, Databricks, Redshift, Athena,
you know, all these different pieces,
and so they're trying to figure out
how to stitch this all together
into a common data foundation
before they can even start their journey.
So let's switch gears now
and talk about some of
our storage services
and how it can help with all this.
This is a map I like to
use to start to layer in
how storage interacts with agents
and the memory requirements.
And really, no matter
if you're going to use
Bedrock AgentCore memory,
which manages the short
term and long term memory,
you've still gotta think
about that data foundation
back to this, you know,
enterprise software provider challenge.
So you wanna start with a data lake,
ideally built on S3 if
you're building in Amazon,
and then using services like S3 Tables.
You know, that's really
going to aggregate your data,
allow you to provide common
security and governance,
and then make the data cataloged,
and discoverable, and
usable by the agents.
So that, you know, is why we use S3
because of the durability, scalability.
Both the AWS first party
services that integrate with it,
but then all these third
party providers as well
that use it as a common data hub.
Building on that, as Venkata discussed,
short term memory is really
the temporary storage
or working memory for information
that the agents are processing.
You know, so it's going to be stored
typically in raw data formats,
and if you have multiple agents
coordinating with each other,
they're going to need exchange
information with each other
so they're going to need to
have a shared storage layer.
Like, if you think of, you
know, a research agent workflow,
you're probably gonna have an agent
that's, you know, discovering
data, you know, maybe looking,
searching through academic papers,
another one that's verifying citations
and rights to use that data,
and then another one that's summarizing,
and this is all gonna be iterative
so they have to communicate.
So given this, we typically recommend
starting with our FSX
family of file services.
There's a whole family to choose from.
They're low latency, scalable, you know,
have a lot of options to save costs
and make it easy to
manage for scratch space
and for this shared memory access.
S3 does play a part
here because ultimately,
you're going to wanna snapshot
that state so that, you know,
if things crash you can quickly recover,
but then you're also going to wanna start
to stage and consolidate
all that short-term memory
and run it through a processing pipeline
to start to create the longer term memory,
the semantic memory that
Venkata talked about.
And so, you know, really
you can use S3 for that.
A couple of other components
of short term memory
are a lot of these agents
can be highly transactional.
So people may want to use a
high performance key value store
to capture state like Dynamo DB.
And then another layer you
wanna build at that level
is a semantic cash layer
oftentimes, which, you know,
might be something like ElastiCache,
which recently introduced vector search
because if you put caching
in front of your LLM, and
your RAG, and your prompting,
even though those storage layers
can be expensive on a dollar basis,
if you reduce the interaction
back and forth with the
LLM and cash responses,
you know, you're quickly driving down cost
and making it a much more
cost effective architecture.
And then finally, you know,
as Venkata also indicated,
you need to think about
semantic memory and RAG
to ground, you know, the LLMs
and get the most accurate results.
And so, you know, we recommend S3 vectors,
which, you know, just went GA today
and Garmin's keynote is
a very cost effective,
highly durable, you know, very
scalable approach for that.
So what do you wanna consider
when you're building that
Data Lake Foundation?
I talked about this enterprise customer
who has all these different platforms
that they're trying to
integrate, you know,
with their own formats,
their own catalogs,
their own security and governance.
The industry has built
a open source solution
to start to address these
challenges called Iceberg.
So if you're building a new data lake,
or even if you have an existing one,
you probably wanna to think
about how to adopt Iceberg
as your data lake foundation
'cause a couple key advantages of it
are it brings a lot of the
data warehouse capabilities
like acid transactions, rollback,
and a number of other
transactional integrity fields
into an object-based data lake.
Secondly, it has Iceberg
rest catalog endpoints,
which start to make it easy to
integrate different catalogs,
data catalogs, that
different provider solutions
have together with each other.
So now you can start to get
better interoperability
between multiple data engines,
both AWS native ones, as
well as a lot of third party
and even open source ones.
So, you know, definitely
consider building Iceberg
as your data foundation.
And to help with that,
we launched S3 tables,
which is a native
Iceberg-managed table within S3.
We launched that back a
year ago here at re:Invent
and have continued to iterate
on it to the point where today
we just announced
intelligent tiering for it.
So really help you
optimize cost for Iceberg,
and native Iceberg
replication across regions
so you can really, if you're
an enterprise, start to build,
you know, highly resilient,
highly available Iceberg.
I wanna divert a minute
and talk about model context protocol
because that's really the key
to stitching all these
components together.
It's an open source standard
that allows AI agents via MCP clients
to communicate with external
tools, data, and services
in a structured way, you know,
so it allows agentic
AI vendors and builders
to start to have access to
potentially thousands of tools
that your agents can call upon
without having to learn all
those individual interfaces.
You just need to know how to speak MCP,
pick the right MCP servers
from a catalog of tools,
and now you can start to build
and if you have data over
all these different devices,
you can start to, you know,
quickly stitch it all together.
Your agents can start to
understand how to access
without knowing how to speak individually
to each one of these devices.
So it's like a USB port for agents
is the way I like to think of it.
And we've started to adopt that
into storage family as well.
You know, we released an
MCP server for S3 tables
so that, you know now, you know,
agents that wanna use tabular data,
store it in Iceberg format,
can speak to and understand
and access data in S3 tables.
You know, one tip I would recommend
when you're thinking about MCP,
particularly if you're just starting out,
is you should really consider
only using it with a read-only capability
and scoping down, you know,
to the least needed
access privileges via IAM,
and these MCP servers,
like the 1-4 S3 tables,
support all that through IAM.
But, you know, really be
deliberate about, you know,
not doing an allow write type capability
unless you're absolutely sure
you have a specific use
case that needs that.
Another key is data discovery.
I mean, you're gonna build this data lake,
you're gonna have all
your data aggregated.
How are agents going to discover this?
Structured data catalogs
have been the foundation
of analytics and data lakes for decades,
but a lot of the data that
AI agents are going to use
is unstructured data of
a lot of different types,
and traditional analytic catalogs
don't really deal with that well.
So you really need to think
about a metadata strategy,
and then, you know, having that metadata
really be discoverable
and consumable by agents
so that they can kind of self-discover
and, you know,
self-describe and understand
the data that they're drawing upon.
So, you know, metadata's really
what makes it actionable.
And to help with that,
we released S3 metadata,
which is a built-in metadata service in S3
that will take system collected metadata,
allow you to augment it with
user-generated metadata,
and then query it
through an iceberg table.
So you can actually use the
MCP server for S3 tables
to also let agents start to discover
metadata and the data itself.
And so the way it works essentially
is you turn it on in S3,
and S3 will populate a metadata table
both with inventory of all the objects,
but also with lineage and, you know,
essentially mutations of the objects.
So you can also start to
use it for governance,
and so when you combine
all these pieces together,
you know, with S3 tables MCP, you know,
AI agents can now really
have true data discovery,
particularly if they have MCP servers
that also speak to things
like iceberg catalogs.
Another key thing we just introduced
in the keynote today for NetApp
was S3 access points for FSX
because one of the challenges
is it's well and good to
say build a data lake,
but a lot of people's data
still lives on premises
in traditional file systems.
So what do you do about that?
Because there are a lot of
legacy applications out there
that don't know how to
speak to object storage.
They, you know, were built to speak
to traditional file systems.
I mean, IDC indicated a
study they did, you know,
that while things are moving
to the cloud, you know,
48% of data still lives on premises
and 29% in the cloud by the end of 2028.
So it is a gradual transition,
and really you need to start
to bring all this data
together in a coherent way.
You know, because while you
could bring the agents to data,
now back to this customer I talked about,
you start to run into
data fidelity issues,
and so this is where FSX access
points for S3 really help
is because you can take data
that lives in traditional file systems,
and if it's in NetApp file systems,
which has been, you know, a
standard on-prem for decades,
you can start to use their
replication capabilities,
snap a copy, maintain a
coherent copy with the cloud
even if you're running on premises,
expose that into S3 as if the
data's living there natively,
and now when you're building
that data foundation,
you've integrated your file data
without having to
maintain a separate copy,
and this is really important
because the same Gartner IDC
study indicated that today,
an enterprise has 6.4 data silos per org
and has to manage 13 copies of data.
So anything you can do to simplify that
is really going to help with, you know,
making your agents have access to data
in a more simplified way.
And then finally, vectors.
Vectors really are the language
of AI because, you know,
you can take increasingly
sophisticated embedding models,
create vectors of any data type,
and then find things that
are semantically similar
both in context, meaning,
and if it's agents,
you know, things that even look the same.
So they really power a lot of this,
everything from RAG to, you
know, intelligence search,
to long-term memory.
And so we launched S3 vectors this summer,
it went GA today, and
it really is designed
to have good enough performance
for a lot of agentic
workflows and RAG workflows.
Lower cost of similarity
search and semantic search
by up to 90% when you look at TCO,
and scale to billions of vectors.
In fact, with the limits
we introduced today,
2 billion vectors per index,
10 billion in 10,000 indexes per bucket,
you can scale to 20 trillion vectors
in a single S3 vector bucket.
So you're not gonna run
into scalability challenges.
And so starting to stitch
all these pieces together,
you can start to do things
like agentic search, you know,
where agents can start to use
conversational information
and choose strategies.
You know, so Venkata
talked about, you know,
a shopping assistant and mapping that
to short and long-term memory.
You can really start
that shopping assistant
can start to pull in, you
know, image data, you know,
and user preference data
and make intelligent
recommendations to buyers
and even start to create images, you know,
using a multimodal model so
that they can start to visualize
what that dress that they
found this one dress,
they want another one like
it, might look like on them.
So, you know, super powerful.
And then just to ground it in
a real world customer example,
BMW group has a 20 petabyte data lake,
they call it their cloud data hub,
of all of their data about their vehicles,
their manufacturing processes,
their warranty information,
and really they wanted to make it simple
for all of their users
to access all these different data types
without being data experts.
And so they built
an agent-powered search
capability for this,
which really can provide
three modes of search,
including direct structured search,
hybrid search across
structured and semantic data,
and pure similarity search
based on the context of the, you know,
natural language query
the user's trying to do.
You know, so it really does
democratize access to data
for all of their users.
So with that, I'm gonna
turn it back to Venkata.
- Thank you, John.
So this is probably my favorite slide
of the overall content.
So we are gonna talk about
when does data actually become memory?
So we saw the first part,
we understood the memory
constructs, right?
And then John covered what
are the building blocks
that facilitate the overall
memory building process?
So now we're bringing both together.
So essentially how when
data becomes memory.
So I guess in AI agentic development,
data and memory are interchangeably used.
But that's fair because
memory is actually data,
but there is a clear distinction
between both the terms.
Data actually becomes memory
when it transforms a passive information
into active component
that informs agent's
behavior and reasoning.
So it's a five stage
transformation process.
So to understand the overall
transformation in a easier way,
let's understand there's a use case.
Let's pick a use case,
which is a customer chat bot
on an e-commerce website.
So that we will pick the overall flow
and then build the overall
transformation pipeline.
So let's say you got
your source data stream.
So on the e-commerce website
you got different channels,
you're getting the order information,
you're getting the like supply
chain merchandise, right?
Whole sorts of information
coming through the sources.
So the first step is to aggregate them.
So you consolidate them into
one single structure, right?
So you bring them all together
typically in a data lake
and you aggregate them at the first stage.
The second step is
encoding or structuring.
So we then take
the structured and unstructured
data that we've aggregated,
and then create vector
embeddings out of them
with enhanced metadata.
So not just creating vector
embeddings would be helpful,
but adding more extensive
metadata to it takes a long way.
So the second step of structuring
is creating vector embeddings
using your preferred model.
All the models available out of Bedrock.
So the third step is storage.
So which is where the
persistent encoded data,
like the data that we have.
So the embeddings that we've created
as part of the stage two, we
create them in stage three.
So this is where S3 vector shines
as a long-term persistent memory store
because it has the scalability attributes
from a latency perspective,
storage, and the performance.
So S3 vectors becomes the preferred
long-term memory store for AI agents.
Fourth is organization.
So essentially, we structure the data
through modeling, indexing,
and relationships.
So conversations are
organized chronologically,
product information is
organized hierarchically,
and order data is, you know,
spread across multiple conversations.
So it's mostly structured
across either time-based, topic-based
from this particular use case perspective.
The last stage is activation or retrieval.
So this is a crucial stage
where information becomes
actionable memory.
Through text search for
exact message matches,
vector search for semantic similarity,
and also graph reversal
for complex relationships.
And then we have the LLM.
So we then utilize the
LLM's built-in capabilities
and go through an iterative process.
So as we are interacting with
the chat bot more iteratively,
it's able to take the
learnings from the interaction,
put it in the storage, again,
goes through a reorganization,
it then gets activated and
then sent back to the LLM.
So this is the iterative process
which essentially gives
the ability for AI agents
to become truly intelligent
and adaptive systems.
So a memory unit is a structured container
that holds information plus
metadata and also relationships
about the information it's learned.
So that essentially makes it
useful for agent reasoning.
So unlike traditional data storage
which essentially treats
all information as equal,
there is a little bit of distinction
that we are trying to form here.
So essentially, memory units
carry several entities.
So first one being the temporal context,
which is when the information was learned.
The second one is a strength indicator,
which means how relevant
the information is
and how reliable it is.
The third is the associative links,
how it connects to other
memories that it has stored.
Fourth, the semantic context,
which is the overall meaning
captured with the interaction.
The last retrieval metadata,
how and when it should be accessed.
So data essentially becomes
memory at the point of storage,
which is step number three.
So when it's collected and stored
with the intent of enabling adaptation
and coherent interaction over time.
So this transformation is
what enables, you know,
the stateless applications
into truly intelligent agents.
So here's a comprehensive architecture
of, you know, deploying
agents using Amazon EKS.
So this is more of a self-managed
approach I would call.
So this essentially highlights
all the components working together.
So you have authentication, model serving,
memory management, and monitoring.
So notice how S3 vectors is integrated
within the memory construct.
So you have the ElastiCache and DynamoDB
as the short-term memory offerings
and then you've got S3
as the working memory
or the scratch pad as John covered.
And then we have S3 vectors
covering the long-term memory.
So this architecture also
includes proper security
with cognitive authentication
and monitoring built in
using Amazon CloudWatch.
So this is a production
ready pattern that can scale
to support multiple agents
and high user volumes.
So now let's look at a weather agent
on how it handles a simple query workflow.
So the agent maintains the session state
or its session state
in S3, as you can see.
It accesses its long term
memory through S3 vectors
and also stores its user content
in Amazon S3 data lake house.
So the MCP server essentially
enables the standardized
integration with external APIs.
So John covered the
MCP, the concept of MCP
and the MCP offering for S3 tables.
So we are essentially
leveraging an MCP server
in this particular example here.
So even the simple example
demonstrates the power
of having a persistent memory and context.
So notice how the agent
just doesn't answer the weather question,
it actually remembers the
use of location preferences
and also able to provide
personalized recommendations as a result.
The cognitive now.
- Okay, so I know you've
all got places to be.
So to wrap this up, you know,
I won't belabor this slide
other than to say, you know,
Rocket Companies is a home
financing organization
that helps people, you know,
through the whole process
of home ownership.
There's a good blog out there
if you search Rocket Companies, AWS,
and agents that'll go
into a lot more depth
of how they did this, their architecture.
But, you know, they used
Amazon Bedrock agents
to build an agent-powered
engagement platform
for their customers that
really helped their customers
resolve their queries in
their ask much more quickly
and gave much improved
guidance, which really helped
with their customer satisfaction.
So look up the Rocket Mortgages blog
if you wanna learn more.
So closing out with a
couple of key learnings
to hopefully tie all this together.
You know, the first is no matter
where you're gonna go
in your agentic journey,
make your data actionable
by building a modern data foundation,
ideally Iceberg-based, on Amazon S3.
And then use cataloging and metadata,
particularly in combination
with MCP servers and tools
so that agents can discover data
and use it and learn and evolve from it.
Second is scale cost effectively
because your data is going
to grow if you're successful,
and so use Amazon S3 as your
data foundation if it works,
and use S3 vectors as your
semantic data foundation
if that meets your needs.
Secondly, you want to iterate rapidly.
So this means you're going
to implement observability
and look at things like your
accuracy, your retrieving,
how your agents are
interacting with each other
and how they're evolving over time.
So you need to have a good
observability story in place.
And then second is make
your agents quickly move
from POC to production
and drive business value
so you're not one of those 40% companies
that's going to fail in your AI project.
You know, which means
consider using AgentCore
even if you want to take
an open source framework
just to reduce the
undifferentiated heavy lifting
you have to do on the security,
the infrastructure, the storage side.
So to wrap up with a few
actions and resources,
you know, we've got a
couple of blogs here.
There's the second one is the
Rocket Story that I mentioned,
and then the third one per
that EKS design pattern
is how to build a
self-managed RAG using EKS
and Amazon S3 vectors that Venkata wrote.
So thank you so much for your time.
We're happy to take questions.